قدرات عسكريه متطوره وفائقه الدقه تمتلكها
البحريه الروسيه التي تضم خمسه تشكيلات
عملياتيه سمحت لها بان تحتل المرتبه
الثانيه في قائمه الاساطير البحريه هذه
التشكيلات تتوزع في كل من بحر الشمال
البحر الاسود بحر البلطيق المحيط الهادئ
وبحر قزوين حيث تنتشر العديد من القطع
البحريه الروسيه وفق اخر دراسه نشرها موقع
رشن شيبسو اسطول بحر الشمال الذي يقع في
سيفراموس يضم سته كاسحات الغامن الاساسيه
وثلاثه واربعين غواصه مختلفه الى جانب
اربعين سفينه وحامله الطائرات الوحيده
العامله لدى روسيا المارشال كوزنيتسوف
بالاضافه الى طرادين يحملان الصواريخ
النوويه الثقيله هذا الاسطول مكلف بالدفاع
في بحار القطب الشمالي وتق الدعم للقوه
النوويه الاستراتيجيه البحريه الروسيه كما
ونوعا في مواجهه اساطيل حلف الناتو اما
اسطول روسيا في المحيط الهادئ مقره
ويضم خمسا وخمسين سفينه متعدده المهام
تمتاز بالدقه وخمسه طرادات وسبعه كاسحات
الغامن وخمسه وعشرين غواصه استراتيجيه
نوويه متعدده الاغراض ودوره مواجهه
الاساطير الامريكيه واليابانيه والصينيه
الشريان الملاحي الاستراتيجي الذي يمكن ان
يتحول لساحه اكبر المعارك البحر الاسود
هناك ايضا اسطول روسي تحديدا في شبه جزيره
القرم دوره تامين حدود روسيا الجنوبيه
الاسطول يضم 47 سفينه حربيه مختلفه وتسعه
كاسحات الغام متنوعه وسبعه سفن وسبع
غواصات هجوميه وفي بحر قزوين هناك ايضا
اسطول يضم 26 سفينه مقاتله وخمس زوارق
انزال وسبعه كاسحات الغامق مركز قياده في
استرخان واستخدمته روسيا في تنفيذ او في
شن هجمات وضربات على اهداف لتنظيم داعش في
سوريا اما اسطول بحر البلطيق الواقع
تحديدا في كاليدينجراد يعتبر مهما بالنسبه
لروسيا للحفاظ على خطوط الملاحه في هذه
المنطقه فهو يضم ما يقرب من 54 سفينه
حربيه وغواصه واحده لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات